The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last, kind of under
the announcements category,
is I want to talk
about the muddy cards.
So I've used those
many times in the past.
Last time was the first
time I handed them out.
And your comments were great.
This was really a good lecture
to have handed them out.
We covered lots of interesting
important concepts.
And so I'm going to review
a couple of things that
came up in the muddy cards.
A couple of the most
positive comments
is people really like the
demos, and they really
like the explanations,
especially with examples.
People particularly
commented it was
really helpful to compute
angular momentum from two
different points.
And you get the
revelation that you
get two very different answers.
So that's a really
important point.
And somebody then
asked the question,
said, well, I
thought that vectors
were independent of
the coordinate system
that you select.
It's true.
A velocity ought
to be a velocity
no matter whether it's
r theta or x, y, z.
But why?
That seems to kind of violate
that notion that vectors should
be independent of coordinates.
And yet we computed an
angular momentum with respect
to one place and respect
to a different place,
and we got different answers.
How do you resolve that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's sort of
like since it's moving,
the coordinates
shouldn't matter.
Like if it was equilibrium,
it wouldn't matter where
you would put the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, well,
you're getting close.
Here was the problem
I think we did.
And we chose this point,
which I'll call 2,
and this point,
which I'll call 1.
And we computed h1.
I'll just call h1 with
respect to point 1.
We'll call this A. We
computed with respect to 1.
And we computed the
angular momentum of A
with respect to 2.
But in this case, angular
momentum of a particle with
respect to some location,
origin of a coordinate system,
is defined as r of the partial
with respect to the coordinate
system crossed with the linear
momentum of the particle that
you're-- we'll call it B here,
just the name of the particle.
The definition-- these
are both vectors.
You arch changing the vector.
It's a different vector.
Because this changes
in the two parts.
So it's not a constant
vector at all.
By its definition,
it is just something
different when you move to a
different place and this piece
changes.
This piece is invariant,
but this piece is not.
And that's the
answer to that one.
Lots of people were still
not clear about Coriolis.
We'll work on that
as time goes by.
And people were
interested in how
to pick reference
frames and so forth.
Somebody made the suggestion,
try using some colored chalk.
It would help.
I don't own any colored chalk.
My assistant just
walked in with some.
She found some at
the last minute.
So I'll try doing that.
That's a good idea.
And someone else says,
take a break in an hour.
And that's a pretty
good idea, too.
I'll try to remember to do that.
So the muddy cards are great.
Please today we'll
do the same thing.
So let's start with this topic.
It's a subject
which we constantly
use throughout the
course doing dynamics.
You have to be
able to figure out
coordinate systems,
degrees of freedom,
drawing free body diagrams.
So I'm going to do a few quick
examples-- coordinates, fbd's.
I picked some examples
here just to emphasize
a few different points.
Here we have a slope.
I've got a wheel.
It's a rigid body.
I pick a preliminary
coordinate system.
Sometimes you do that just
to help you think about it.
And now let's talk about
degrees of freedom.
What do we mean by
degrees of freedom?
I'm going to define it as
the number of independent
coordinates necessary
to describe the motion.
So it's the number of
independent coordinates
that you need.
Now, with few exceptions,
I can compute that
by multiplying 6 times
the number of rigid bodies
in the problem plus 3 times
the number of particles
minus the constraints,
the number of constraints.
So this is the number
of rigid bodies.
This is the number of particles.
And C, this is the constraints.
So take a look at this problem.
A wheel's a rigid body.
The difference between a
rigid body and a particle
is a rigid body is big enough.
It has mass at some extent.
Its rotational
inertia will matter.
So here we've got a wheel.
So we've got certainly one
rigid body but no particles.
So in this case, n is 1, m is 0.
And so the number of
degrees of freedom
that we should come up
with in this problem is
going to look like 6 minus C.
And so then the
problem becomes--
let's identify what the
constraints are in the problem.
So I drew my initial
little coordinate system
just so that I can use language
like x, y, and z direction.
So z's coming out of the board.
So in this problem,
let's figure out
how many constraints there are.
How about the y direction?
The simplest kind of
constraints are things
that just allow no motion.
Can it move in the y direction?
No, OK, so y, y dot,
y double dot, are 0.
So that's a hard constraint.
You can't move through the
wall in the y direction.
You have to make assumptions
when you're doing problems.
You have to try to simplify
things as much as you can
so that you make them easy.
So really I'm going to
assume in this problem-- I
haven't shown any constraints
or wheels or guides or rollers.
But I'm going to assume that it
won't move in the z direction.
So that's another constraint.
So this implies 1.
This implies another constraint.
If I don't do this, if
I don't assume that,
then I just end up with
another equation of motion.
For every degree of freedom,
you end up with a problem.
You're going to need
an equation of motion.
So if I did not make
this assumption,
I'd say that the summation of
the forces in the z direction
is equal to 0.
And that's equal to the
mass times the acceleration
of the body in the
z acceleration.
It's a vector, vector component.
And then you just
say, oh well, that's
a trivial equation of motion.
And so you could deal
with it that way.
But we'll just assume that
we have no motion in the z.
And that gives us
another constraint.
Now we can assume
again that there's
constraints in the problem,
or it's well behaved,
in that the thing
won't fall over.
It won't roll over.
And it won't change direction
running down the hill.
So we'll assume no rotation
about the x or y axes.
So that implies two
more constraints.
And finally, the constraints
can come in many flavors.
Finally we know
that in this problem
that I need to think
in terms of a rotation.
So there's a positive rotation
in that coordinate system.
So now I have a
rotational coordinate
that I can think about.
But this now says that
if there's no slip,
I can say that the distance
it rolls down the hill
is minus r theta.
That's a constraint.
x and theta are not
independent of one another.
We're looking for the number
of independent coordinates
required to completely
describe the motion.
x and r are not independent
because of this no slip
condition.
And so that implies yet another.
OK, so we've got one, two,
three, four, five constraints.
And we said that the
number of degrees
of freedom in this problem is
equal to 6 minus 5, which is 1.
So you take the
single coordinate.
You could have told me
that long ago that that's
what it's going to take.
But this is the
sort of thinking you
have to go through to come up
with all these constraints.
So this is going to take
a single coordinate.
It could be x.
It could be theta.
But you don't actually
need them both.
You use them both for a while,
because it's convenient.
But in the final
analysis, you'll
be able to write an
equation of motion
just in terms of x or
just in terms of theta.
OK, free body diagram of
our wheel-- we said no slip.
So here's your slope.
You know you've got mg.
You know there's going to be
a normal force from the slope.
There may also be
some tangential force
that makes it impossible
for it not to slip, some f.
So there's the free body
diagram, in this case.
What if-- I'll do e here, or do
a case ii here, slip allowed.
Then how many
constraints do we have?
Just four.
Because now you can no
longer say that this is true.
They're independent
of one another.
They take on values not
controlled by this formulation.
So 6 minus 4 gives you 2.
And you're going
to end up having
to have both x and theta
probably as your chosen
coordinates to do the problem.
And you'll end up with
two equations of motion.
So I've got a hockey puck here.
I've drawn kind of a
3D perspective of this.
So it has a coordinate
system out here.
The z-axis is going like that.
So here's my z.
Here's my x.
Here's my y in the
plane of the ice
that this thing is sliding on.
So this is my z-coordinate.
And I have string
wrapped around it.
And I've got a piece of
string coming off like that.
And I'm pulling on
it with some tension.
Because otherwise
the only constraints
are it's sitting on
this icy surface, which
I'm going to assume
is-- well, I don't even
have to assume
it's frictionless.
I could.
So let's figure out how
many equations of motion
we're going to need here.
So the number of degrees
of freedom, 6 times-- this
is a rigid body.
It's not a particle.
And there's only one of them.
So it's 6 times 1 minus C and
the number of constraints.
So can it move into the
table, into the surface?
No, so that's a constraint in z.
Are there any constraints
in the x or y?
It can rotate about z.
But it can't rotate
about the x or y-axes.
All right, so constraint
into z is one.
Can't rotate about
x or y-- two, three.
Are there any others?
Who thinks I may
have missed one?
OK, I'd say we've got 6 minus 3.
We're going to need
three equations of motion
to be able to actually describe
the motion of this thing.
And we'd probably use--
this is a pretty good
coordinate system.
We'd probably use an x, a y,
and some theta with respect
to z-axis.
All right, another
quick example--
so we've got a rod
leaning against a wall.
It's length L. Actually,
I don't want to do that.
It's L long.
It's got a center of mass here
at the middle, uniform rod.
Let this be x, y, z
coming out of the board,
maybe give it an angle here just
to help us describe motions.
You might start off with a
preliminary little coordinate
system just so you could
think that, OK, no motion
in the x, no rotation in this.
But once you get
the problem, you're
ready to set up the
equations of motion,
you might decide, OK, I
know I need two coordinates.
And the ones I've preliminarily
chosen aren't too good.
Then you change, and you
pick the really good ones.
But I'm just making the
preliminary assessments
so I can assess
the problem here.
Again, the degrees of
freedom-- 6 times 1 minus C.
Because I only have
one rigid body.
Now, the constraints here
are a little more subtle.
Let me just discuss
these two points.
What can you say about
the motion at point A?
This is right here where
it touches the wall.
This thing is sliding
down the wall.
It might be
frictionless, might not.
Whether or not friction
acts doesn't really
change the number of
degrees of freedom
unless you invoke
things like no slip.
What can you say
kinematically about motion,
about the motion at A?
Does the wall
restrict the motion?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: In what direction?
AUDIENCE: x.
PROFESSOR: In which direction?
PROFESSOR: In x
direction, right.
So is this body constrained
in the x direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
I hear a no.
I hear some yeses.
What about at B?
Is it constrained at B?
In the--
AUDIENCE: y.
PROFESSOR: y direction, OK.
I didn't bring my big foam disk.
But earlier in the term,
I said that the definition
of translation is that
all points on a rigid body
do what if you're rectilinear
or curvilinear translation as
opposed to rotation?
AUDIENCE: Move in parallel.
PROFESSOR: All points move
in parallel, exactly right.
That means that if we use
real strict definitions
of translation and rotation,
that if I constrain
the motion of any
point on that object,
that object is now not allowed
to translate in that direction
by the definition
of translation.
So this point constrains
it in the x direction.
This constrains it
in the y direction.
And we're going to-- so it's
constrained in translation.
And that implies 2.
And b, we'll assume
that z motion is 0.
We'll just assume
there's nothing
going on out of the plane.
So that gives me another one.
And I'll assume no rotation.
I'm not going to allow any
rotation in this problem.
I'm not interested in rotation
about the x or about the y,
about these axes.
And that implies two more.
So we have two,
three, four, five.
And I better not have any
more than that or the thing
can't move.
So in this case, this
is 6 minus 5 equals 1.
I need a single coordinate
to describe the motion.
And if you look at
it, you say, well,
that's kind of
intuitive and obvious.
If I specify the
x position here,
I could figure everything out.
If I know the length and the x,
I could figure out where it is.
If I know the y
position and the length,
I could figure out where it is.
If I know theta, I
could figure it out.
I only need one.
But that strict
definition of translation
is really helpful here.
This thing, this object,
is in pure rotation.
And if it's in pure rotation,
it must rotate about some point.
Where?
You know how to find that?
What's the velocity here?
It's got gravity acting on
it, so it's probably down.
But it's parallel to the wall.
It has to be.
What's the velocity here?
It's got to be
parallel to the wall.
If I draw perpendicular
to that-- if I'm saying,
this is rotation.
All points in the body
rotate at the same rate.
But their speed is
determined by the distance
away from the
center of rotation.
But if it's pure
rotation, there must be
a center of rotation somewhere.
And it must be perpendicular
to any velocity vector.
So you draw the perpendicular.
You draw the perpendicular.
And here is the instantaneous
center of rotation, the ICR.
There's a little short
section in the book on that.
When this thing drops down to
here, same kind of arguments
hold.
But the center of rotation
has changed locations.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is this
not translating x and y?
PROFESSOR: So now let's talk
about the center of mass.
So she asked-- excuse me, I
should repeat the question.
You guys aren't holding
me to that very well.
Raise your hands if I don't
repeat an important question.
She says, is it not translating?
We've determined
that-- let me ask you,
does the center of mass move?
Does Newton's second
law apply to the motion
of the center of mass?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's got to.
So the center of
mass translates--
no doubt about that.
Newton's second
law applies to it.
So we're not saying
that there isn't motion
of the system in the x and y.
We're just saying that that
motion is caused by rotation.
It's not caused by
what is strictly
defined as translation.
Free body diagram,
the reason-- let's
think about a free
body diagram for this.
Here's our rod.
There must be-- I'll let
it be frictionless to keep
the problem simple for a moment.
That means there must
be just a normal force
in the x direction here.
I'll call it Nx.
And there must be a normal
force in the y, call it Ny.
The center of mass,
there must be an Mg.
So now that I set the
problem up this way,
how many unknowns are
there in the problem?
If I want to calculate literally
the motion of this thing,
find an equation of
motion and solve it,
how many unknowns do I have?
How many do you think?
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: I hear one.
I see two on the board.
But is two the right answer?
I hear three.
Who said three?
All right, what's the third one?
AUDIENCE: Acceleration?
PROFESSOR: How do you
describe acceleration
with a coordinate of some kind?
So there's yet another unknown.
It's probably the thing that
you're trying to solve for.
It's actually the motion itself
described by theta for x or y,
whatever you do.
There's at least three unknowns
in this problem the way
you see it in this
free body diagram.
So you've got to figure
out ways around that.
This instantaneous
center of rotation
gives you one possible
way around that.
Because about an instantaneous
center, it's not moving.
It's an axis.
It's not moving.
We have a little
formula that says
the time rate of change of
angular momentum-- torque
is related to the time rate
of change of angular momentum.
And you can have a messy
formula or a not so messy.
And it's not so messy when the
axis of rotation is stationary.
So at this instant in time,
the axis is stationary.
You can say that the
torques about this point,
the ICR, summation of
the torques with respect
to the ICR, is equal to d, is
now a rigid body with respect
to the ICR, dt.
OK, in this problem,
what are the torques?
Where do the torques come from?
Is there any torque
caused by Nx?
No, because there's no
moment on it, right?
It's pointing right
at the center.
Same thing-- no
torque caused by this.
You want to find equations
that get rid of unknowns.
So neither unknown
appear in this equation.
Where does the torque come from?
Gravity, right?
And it's going to be some
Mg times a moment arm.
And the moment arm is
going to be like that.
So it's an L over 2 sine theta.
And the sine you'll
have to figure out
from an r cross and f.
So you have an i cross
j, gives you a k.
But it's in the minus direction.
So I think it'll come out minus.
But I could be wrong.
I did that on the fly.
So we're not going to
go further with this.
But the instantaneous centers of
rotation could be really handy.
OK, a final example
in this stuff--
how are we doing on time?
Couple of carts, so the
floor constrains the motion.
And I've got a spring and a
dashpot and an M1 and an M2.
And I want to figure
out how many-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious.
Why is torque negative
in your earlier solution?
PROFESSOR: Let's just
figure out r cross f.
So my r-- you're saying,
why is the torque negative?
The r is L/2 in the i hat.
And the gravity crossed with
the force, which is Mg in the--
but it's minus Mg in the j hat.
So i cross j is positive k.
But the minus sign
comes from there.
AUDIENCE: What is that over
to the left [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm working
on the center of mass here.
That's my equation.
And this thing is L long.
So half of the
length must be L/2.
And I'm interested in this
side of the right triangle.
AUDIENCE: Why are you interested
in that side rather than
the side that
connects it to the--
PROFESSOR: Because this side
crossed with that gives me 0.
There's no moment.
So this is a moment equation.
I'm trying to compute moments.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Should the moment
come from the ICR load?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
I don't know what I'm thinking.
I could have messed this up.
It's got to be about the ICR.
So the force is down.
Ooh, it's got to be this one.
I messed up-- good catch.
So that's a cosine, still L/2.
You've got a theta.
You have a-- this is also theta.
And we're looking
now for this side.
Eh, it's still
sine theta, right?
Does the sign still
work out the right way?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Good, OK,
I've got to keep rolling.
I've got something else really
fun I want to talk about.
So let's do this
example quickly.
This is mostly to get you to
think about free body diagrams.
This-- two rigid bodies.
The degrees of freedom
quickly here-- 6 times 2.
There's no particles--
minus c, so 12 minus c.
Now how many?
What does your
intuition tell you?
How many independent
coordinates is it
going to take to
solve this problem?
Hold up your fingers.
I see two, one, two, one.
OK, one or two.
Well, I think you can find 10
constraints in this problem.
If you assume it
doesn't roll over
and you assume it doesn't
move, you can find 10.
You're going to need
two coordinates.
Because just because you've
got a spring and a dashpot,
they don't fix.
They don't say there's
any particular relation
between the motion of this
and the motion of that.
You're going to need an
independent coordinate
to describe the--
whoops, 2 times 6.
This is 12 minus 10.
You don't need an
independent coordinate
to describe the motion
of each of these masses.
And I'd probably choose a
coordinate that, let's say,
goes from the center
of mass of this one.
I'll call it x1, center of
mass of this one call it x2.
And because I've been doing
problems, vibration problems
and stuff like this,
for a long time,
I'll tell you it's smart to
start your coordinates at 0
when you have zero
spring forces.
Or from the static
equilibrium position--
that's the good place to start.
So then your answer, if you're
at the static equilibrium
position, then any non-zero
answers that come out of it
are movement around that point.
That's what mother nature does.
A spring hanging on a
mass hanging on a spring,
it has a static
equilibrium position.
The vibration occurs around it.
Your car is sitting
on the ground.
The vibration is around its
static equilibrium position.
So you usually choose these
at the static equilibrium.
And you'll find that that
makes for the simplest
equations of motion.
They tend to not have
constants on the right hand
side that's caused by gravity
or offsets or things like that.
So this thing, actually a
problem very similar to this
is on your homework.
The homework says, go
find what these 10 are.
So you can name
them pretty fast.
That's why I'm not
doing it for you.
What I do want to
do quickly here
is just talk about how
you assign free body
diagrams for this problem.
Because people, one of
the most easiest thing
to get confused
about is figuring out
the directions of
the forces that
come from the springs in the
dashpots, which direction
acts on each.
So I've made my
x's so that x1 is
0 when this thing is at its
static equilibrium position.
And I'm going to start by
assuming that x1 and x1 dot are
positive.
You just establish
positive motions.
And you deduce the direction of
the spring and dashpot forces.
OK, and you do
them one at a time.
The problems we're
doing here are linear.
Spring force is equal to kx.
Dashpot forces are Bx dot.
So they're linear problems.
So the superposition holds.
You can just do these
conceptually one at a time
and figure them out.
And then you add
them all together
to get the complete answer.
So if x1 moves in the
positive direction,
what is the direction
that that spring
puts on this mass as a result?
Which direction is it?
And my coordinate
system is positive.
Here's x1.
We'll do the same thing here.
Here's x2.
So if it moves in the positive
direction out to here,
what is the spring going to do?
No other motion allowed in
the system, just that one.
It moves a little bit.
What does the spring
do on that mass?
AUDIENCE: Push back.
PROFESSOR: Push back kx.
And I let the sign be indicated
by the direction of the arrow.
And I'll use that when I write
out my equation of motion.
OK, now I'm going to
assume a positive bx1, so
its velocity in that direction.
What does the dashpot do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Resist
or [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Resist.
PROFESSOR: Pushes back, right?
OK, so you have another
force here, bx1 dot.
Now, this is if you
have two bodies.
You have to have two free
body diagrams, one for each.
But I need to know what's
the effect of x2 and x2 dot
on this body.
Well, let's just go
do the same thing.
Let's let x2 be positive.
Now it's the only motion.
I have a positive movement of
x2 that stretches the spring.
What is that spring
force applied to this?
What direction is it in?
This body is moving in that way.
AUDIENCE: Positive x direction.
PROFESSOR: Which
way is the spring
going to pull on this thing?
It's going to pull on it, right?
So k, by amount kx2, and
of positive velocity,
to the right.
It makes the dashpot open up.
What direction is the force
that dashpot puts on this?
AUDIENCE: Positive x.
PROFESSOR: bx2 dot.
And now in this problem,
except for gravity,
I've got a normal
force f and an Mg down.
But all the action,
all the motion,
is in the horizontal direction.
I can write out an equation of
motion for the first rigid body
here.
And that's a sum of the forces
in the x direction on body
one-- I'll give this
a 1 here-- in the x
is equal to M1 x1 double dot.
And now I can just write it out.
It is k x2, because
that one's positive,
minus x1 plus b x2
dot minus x1 dot.
And that has the signs right.
And the whole key is just one at
a time assume positive motions
and deduce what
happens, and then use
the arrows, the direction of
the arrows, to set the signs.
And now there's your
equation of motion.
Now we can do the
same thing, sum
of the forces on 2 in the x 2
direction, M2 x2 double dot.
And now we would do
exactly the same thing.
So positive motion of x1,
what does it do over here?
It gives me a force through
the spring in which direction,
positive or negative?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
PROFESSOR: Right,
so now you just
end up with a kx1, bx1 dot.
And you'll find
that kx2 bx2 dot.
And you sum it up.
And you'll end up-- this should
switch around, k x1 minus x2
plus b x1 dot minus x2 dot.
I've got two
equations of motion.
And they're mixed.
So each one has both
coordinates in it.
So this problem has two
questions of motion,
and they're coupled.
They're not independent.
You have to solve them together.
OK, now we're going to
move on to a subject which
has come up in conversation.
People have asked about
this lots of time.
And they say, what about
the centrifugal force?
And you sometimes use the
term "fictitious force."
How many of you use or heard the
word used "fictitious force"?
And how many of you heard us say
that centripetal acceleration
is not a force, it's
an acceleration?
And yet we love to
talk about this concept
of centrifugal force,
which doesn't exist.
But it trips us all up.
Because it's handy
to think about it.
And so we're going to talk
about fictitious forces now.
They're handy.
But they are dangerous.
You really have to
understand your fundamentals
if you're going to use the
concept of fictitious forces
without getting
yourself in trouble.
OK, what is a fictitious force?
Well, Newton's law, let's
start there, Newton's second.
Sum of the forces
external on the body
equals a mass
times acceleration.
It's a vector equation.
So we can break it down
into its components.
So a fictitious force, you take
the true acceleration times
the mass.
So you have a fictitious force.
It's going to multiply the true
acceleration times the mass
and put it on the summation of
forces side of the equation.
That's really all it is.
And you move it over to
this side of the equation.
And you think of it as a force.
So what you've
done is you've said
that the summation of the forces
minus Ma-- because to move it
over here, you've got to
subtract it from this side--
equals 0.
And you're saying,
I'm just going
to think of this as a force.
And it makes this whole equation
be conveniently equal to 0.
But now, that's
kind of abstract.
Let's see if we can figure
out an example or two
to illustrate this.
I'm sure you've done
this problem in physics.
I'm going to pick a
really elementary problem
so you don't get hung up on
the physics to start with.
This is the elevator problem.
You've got cables pulling it up.
You've got some scales in here,
and you're standing on it.
Here's your center of mass.
We'll call that A. And I
need a coordinate system,
my inertial system.
Newton's law only applies
in inertial systems.
So here's my x.
I called this z here.
I'll call this y.
So I need to write
an equation of motion
about this person riding
up in the elevator.
We take a look at it.
How many degrees of freedom?
Intuitively obvious--
it's probably how many?
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: One-- all
sorts of constraints.
It's only going up.
So we're going to say we
need one degree of freedom.
Free body diagrams--
well, this object
has some force pushing up on it.
This is the person.
This is your mass.
It has a force pulling
down on it, mg.
And that's it.
Now this N is going
to work out to be
what the scales read, right?
Because it's coming
through the scales.
So that's really what
we're looking for.
And the problem here is, define
the weight on the scales.
So we say that the summation of
the forces in the y direction--
and in this problem,
we would say
it's the mass times the
acceleration of point
A with respect to O.
And the sum of those
forces-- you've
got an N minus mg.
And that's a pretty
simple equation.
Now I'm going to specify.
It's given that acceleration
of A with respect to O
is 1/4 of g.
So that's what the cables
in the elevator are doing.
It's making this
thing move, and it's
going up at 1/4 of g,
the N acceleration.
So it's getting
faster and faster.
OK, so if I solve this
for N, I will get--
let me stop there for a second.
It's normally what
I would just do.
But since we're talking
about fictitious forces,
I need to go through
that step for a second.
So now I say that,
well, the summation
of the forces in the y direction
here minus M acceleration of A
with respect to O, that
total is equal to 0.
And that then is N minus
Mg minus M times g over 4.
And now I have taken
this upward acceleration.
And I've treated
it like a force.
I've just moved it
to this other side,
set the whole thing equal to 0.
This is the fictitious force.
I'm going to say, OK, that's
all the forces in the system,
solve for N. And of course you
get N is M times g plus g/4.
And that's 5/4 mg.
And so you read 25% heavier.
It's a really trivial example.
But the notion is
that you think of this
as a force that's been applied.
It's the mass times
acceleration with a minus
sign in front of it.
It'll always turn out like that.
It's minus the mass
times the acceleration.
Now, the acceleration can come
from Coriolis acceleration.
It can come from
centripetal acceleration.
So if we do this in
a rotating thing,
this fictitious force might
be the centrifugal force,
which is minus M times the
centripetal acceleration.
And we'll do an
example like that.
All right, stop-- there we go.
OK, trivial example--
let's see if we can
find something a little harder.
How are we doing on time?
We're doing pretty good.
So let's do an example
where the notion is really
quite powerful.
Now, I showed you
this last time.
And we talked a lot about--
we did the time derivative is
the angular momentum.
And we computed the
torques that this thing
exerts around different
axes with respect
to the point of
attachment to this.
Well, this is an
example which, if you're
comfortable with
fictitious forces,
you can figure out those
torques really rather quickly.
So I'm going to-- these
two problems are identical.
This problem, or with a
shaft running like that,
are really exactly identical.
But I'm going to pretend that
my thing is made this way.
Because it makes it easier
to see where these torques
are coming from.
So here's my z.
And I've got my rotation
about the z-axis.
Here's this mass,
my coordinates.
Here's my r hat.
Here's my z k hat, is
this distance here.
And I'm going to set conditions
in the problem, my rotation
rate.
It's also theta dot
about the k z-axis.
And omega dot, theta
double dot-- also in the k.
It's not restricted.
So I'm allowing this
thing to accelerate.
But r dot equals
r double dot is 0.
So it's not changing a position.
It's just fixed.
And I need to figure out
the forces on this thing
and talk about how we
might consider some of them
as fictitious forces.
So let's think about
in the r direction--
summation of the forces here
in this r hat direction.
So it's one vector component.
I don't have to carry along
all of the other baggage.
It's equal to-- and
I'll call this B.
This is going to be
the point about which I
care about things.
There's a fixed coordinate
system here, Oxyz.
But then a rotating coordinate
system-- we'll call this A.
And it's going to
have my coordinates.
I'll use polar
coordinates, r theta z.
But this one rotates.
But it also has its origin
right there coincident with O.
So the sum in the r
direction, then, we
have the mass times
the acceleration of B
with respect to O. And the
acceleration of B with respect
to O is the
acceleration of-- we'll
just write out the whole formula
using cylindrical coordinates.
r double dot minus r theta dot
squared, this is in the r hat,
plus r theta double
dot plus 2r dot theta
dot in the theta hat direction.
That's my full expression
for-- whoops, not quite full.
Forgot a term, right?
There we go.
That's my full expression
for acceleration
using cylindrical coordinates,
but with a moving,
possibly translating and
rotating reference frame.
This piece here counts for what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Acceleration of what?
In general, why do
we have that term?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's the
translational acceleration
of the A frame.
So we can account for it.
In this case, what is that?
OK, so this term is 0.
But this formula you
really need to know.
Because it accounts for
all of the accelerations
in the problem.
You know that, you
just go in and start
assigning, picking out things.
What's this?
0.
Is this 0?
No, how about this one?
Not 0-- I'm allowing
it to accelerate.
This one-- definitely 0.
And this one?
0.
So I don't have many
terms left in this.
So this then is the mass times
minus r theta dot squared.
And this is r hat plus
r theta double dot
in the theta hat direction.
Now I said I was summing
the forces in the r.
I put all of them
in at the moment.
It may be smarter to do that.
Let me reverse course here.
This is the vector summation
of all the forces for a moment.
And then we'll take
the r component next.
So just the r
component, the summation
of the forces in the
r, we look at this,
and we say, oh, it's
just that minus Mr theta
dot squared r hat.
So that's the r direction.
But now we need a
free body diagram.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why did you take
the 2r theta [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, because
that's r dot 0.
So in my r direction,
this is my acceleration.
That's the only acceleration
in the r direction.
It's what we know
to be centripetal.
And the minus tells
us it's inward.
Free body diagram-- need that.
So looking-- a side view.
Here's your bead.
I'm going to draw it
as an unknown here.
There is an unknown
force in the r direction
that comes from
this bar holding it.
It's applying-- there's
got to be a force that
makes this go in a circle.
And that bar is
what provides it.
It's the only thing [INAUDIBLE].
I'll just call
this unknown and r.
And I'm just drawing it
in the positive direction.
The way you can do this, if
you're not sure the direction,
draw it positive.
And the sign that
falls out tells you
what the right answer is.
There'll be some force in
the z provided by the rod.
There'll be Mg.
And that should be it.
If we did a top
view, then there'd
be an unknown in
the theta direction.
You'd also see the N
in the r direction.
And anything else?
No, the Mg is down
where you can't see it.
So these are your two
free body diagrams.
So now, in this direction,
this is the acceleration.
And the external
forces are just that.
So the sum of the forces is Nr.
Now I want to treat it,
bring in this concept
of a fictitious force.
I'm going to move
the acceleration
term to the other side.
Nr-- unknown positive.
Now I'm going to move
that acceleration
term over here minus--
ah, but now it's
minus the acceleration.
So this term looks like
that, has a minus sign.
If you move it over here,
that actually becomes plus,
equals 0.
Now this is your
fictitious force.
Sometimes people call
them inertial forces.
And it acts like it's
pulling out on the object.
So the force that the mass
appears to apply to the rod
is this centrifugal
force pulling out.
And of course now
we can solve for Nr.
And we find it's minus Mr
theta dot squared, which
we knew all along.
It's the force applied
to the mass by the arm
as it spins around.
It has to pull in on it to
make it go in that circle.
Now, we could do the same
thing in the theta direction.
The theta direction will
have an Mr theta double dot.
And when we look at the
theta free body diagram,
it's plus N theta.
You could solve that,
and you immediately
come up with a solution for the
force in the theta direction.
I'm just going to
write that one down.
When you solve for this
one, you get a minus sign.
This one ends up plus,
Mr theta double dot.
I'm not going to go through the
gyrations of getting to this.
You can do that one.
Now, I want to do one
quick thing with this.
Once you develop
confidence in knowing
when you can use a fictitious
force and not get in trouble,
this is the sort of
thing you might do.
Here's my system.
It's rotating.
And I want a quick estimate
of, what's the torque?
What's the bending moment about
this point caused by the fact
that it is the
centripetal acceleration?
Well, centripetal
acceleration is
equivalent to having this
fictitious force outward
on this of an amount
Mr theta dot squared.
And this is the moment arm z.
what's the torque that that
causes about this point?
This is just levers now,
forces and lever arms.
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: No, not 0.
About this point
here-- this is O.
And I've got that
centrifugal force pulling out
on this fictitious force.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: zMR of
theta dot squared?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in
the-- this direction,
which is theta, right?
So that's the moment the
torque about this point caused
by that-- torque at O is
minus Mr theta dot squared
times z, the moment arm.
And it's not minus.
It's in that direction.
So it's plus.
It's in the theta hat
direction, the torque,
that that force is
applying about this point.
We could have solved
this problem the way
we did in the last
lecture, very carefully
going through the dh dt's
and following it all out.
And we would have gotten
that answer for the torque
except for a minus sign.
Now, why the difference?
This is the torque that
the centripetal force
causes down here.
When you do dh dt,
you get the torque
required to make what's
happening happen.
It's just the opposite.
This is the torque.
This is putting about that.
There must be an equal
and opposite torque
that this system puts
on this arm out here
to keep it from flopping out.
So this is applying
a torque here.
It must resist with a torque.
And so when you do
dh dt, you're going
to end up with a minus Mr
theta dot squared theta hat.
So you've got to be
careful what you mean.
But from an engineering
point of view,
if I were just trying to
calculate the bending moment
down here and deciding whether
or not this shaft sticking out
here is going to
break off or not,
I could make a very quick
estimate of the bending moment
by knowing this centrifugal
force times the moment arm.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that supposed to
be a z in the dh dt expression?
Does there have to be
a z in that expression?
PROFESSOR: A v, a velocity?
AUDIENCE: A z.
PROFESSOR: A z, yeah, right.
I'm just getting a little
speedy in writing the equation.
Good catch.
All right, so now, we also have
a theta direction thing here,
right?
We can think of a fictitious
force in the theta direction.
And that was the Mr
theta double dot term.
Does it generate torques that
you could quickly compute?
So as this thing is
trying to accelerate
in the positive acceleration,
omega dot, theta double dot,
it's trying to accelerate
into the board.
The bar is having to push
that thing into the board.
There's a force in the
positive theta hat direction.
But the fictitious
inertial force
is the mass pushing back on
the rod, pushing this way,
Mr theta double dot
pushing this way.
What moments does that
cause about this point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So there's
actually two moment arms.
If you have a force this
way now, the force in,
I'll call it, the
theta direction
is Mr theta double dot.
Now, this is my
fictitious force.
This is this fictitious force.
It's in the minus
theta hat direction.
It's pushing back.
It's in the minus theta hat
direction, Mr theta double dot.
And a torque is some R
cross with the force.
And this R is that, RBA.
And it's composed of r
R hat and z k hat here.
So we have to do
a little r r hat
plus z k hat crossed with minus
Mr theta double dot theta hat.
So you get an r hat cross
theta gives you a k.
A k cross theta
hat gives you an r.
You're going to get
two terms out of this.
One is going to look like
Mr squared theta double dot.
And that's a torque.
And that is the one that
it takes to-- that's
the torque about this axis.
There's a force times
this moment arm.
That's a torque about this axis.
That's the actual torque it
takes to speed this thing up.
And then there's a torque
about this axis, which is
this length times this force.
And that's the other term.
That'll give you the
term in the R direction.
It'll be a twist.
It'll be trying to twist
this bar like that.
Because there's a force
in this direction.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems
like these forces
are coming from the systems.
They aren't even fictitious.
PROFESSOR: So she's asking,
it's like the forces are real.
But the force-- I
mean, this is why
fictitious forces, this concept
of them, is so dangerous.
It's because it's
really tempting
to start thinking of
them like real forces.
So any time you get stuck,
you go back to the basics.
And you say, Newton's
law, F equals ma,
you see torques is dh dt
plus that v cross p term
if you need it.
And you work it out carefully
using all the vector math.
And then you are
dealing-- and then
Coriolis, centripetal, Euler
terms are only accelerations.
You treat them as
pure accelerations.
That's all they are.
Now, to cause accelerations,
you need to apply forces.
And we give these forces names.
Because it's
helpful conceptually
to think about these
things as forces sometimes.
But they are not real forces.
But it's quick and easy.
If you get too
comfortable with them,
they are great assets
to your intuition.
So I know immediately
just looking
at this thing, as soon
as I see a machine that
has a part that rotates like
this, I say, rotational motion.
That's central, circular
motion, must be the equivalent
of a centrifugal force.
This mass is going to
pull in that direction.
Because it's going
around and around.
And it's going to cause a
moment about this thing.
I know for sure that's
got to be there.
And if I'm going to
do it rigorously,
I call it centripetal
acceleration.
And I compute.
It's really the force that
this bar puts on that mass
to make it go in a circle.
But it's handy to
think of it as a force
if what I'm interested
in is the force.
The other even better-- let's
go back to the old really simple
demonstration.
This thing going
around constant speed,
there's definitely a
tension in the string.
And I am pulling.
The tension is inward, right?
That tension causes
an acceleration
of r theta dot squared.
And that acceleration is inward.
But it's easy.
If you ask me, come
on, Kim, quick,
tell me, what's the
tension in the string,
I just say, that's easy--
Mr theta dot squared,
centrifugal force.
They're handy.
But any time you get stuck,
go back and be really strict
and say, what's acceleration?
And what's real external forces?
Gravity is an external force.
The force that the bar puts on
the mass, that's a real force.
But these other things
are just accelerations.
All right, OK, hey, perfect.
I didn't get to the thing
I really wanted to do.
So I'll do it next time.
And I'm going to
show you this thing.
And I want you to fill
out your muddy cards.
I'm giving you a couple minutes.
So this is a mechanical shaker.
You see it moving already.
And we're going to talk
about that next time.